okay so um
yeah welcome so for those of you who
haven't decided okay they left
so yeah there's still a few seats at the
front for those of you who just come in
um you can come closer to me if you
don't mind
um so yeah like there is actually some
hands-on exercise after
my presentation so like you can go to
that link to go to that github repo
which is bisterly and then slash pi data
ldn 22.
okay
um
so yeah i
i give you the link early just because
like uh you know the internet is not the
best so it may take some time to
download but i would i would definitely
guide you back to the repo later
um yeah so
hello how's how's everybody how's the
lunch
good
yeah good okay good so uh i hope you're
not too full so uh you know
well if you fall asleep i hope it's not
my fault so
right so uh
i'm checked so this is uh you can you
can kind of uh make i hope you can see
well so like you can follow me on
twitter if you want
um
so uh just to like give everybody an
idea what we're gonna do so this
workshop actually um there will be a
presentation to start uh so it would
take around 20 minutes this is not very
accurate actually so um it may change
but
if i finish the presentation early
you'll get more time to um
to work on the uh the coding uh
you know
that would be great so there's also like
another way to find the github rapport
is to go to my github which is just
check thing my name and then you would
uh from all my repository you will find
the k n recommender so that that's the
one that you should go to
um
and then i'll try to also like give you
an idea of how that project was
structured um but i hope you can like
kind of
you know complete the project yourself
so uh i do believe that the best way to
learn is to try it yourself uh rather
than me telling you what to do but
that's also like kind of a solution that
i was hidden in another branch if you
really need some help you can go there
as well um so without further ado oh so
for new people i love seeing new people
please comment there's two seats here
there's also a few over there so you're
welcome to come join us
um
so
uh i think i'll just start by giving
some uh kind of background information
about what we're going to do today i
hope you uh you already have an idea if
not then i'm just gonna tell you so uh
we're gonna build a recommender so what
is a recommender so um
we uh we kind of you know experience
that every day right like you know if
you have subscribed to netflix you know
that after you you you know when you
join you have to pick a few movie that
you like and then you will get a bunch
of recommendations so um
a lot of recommender uh is kind of uh
you know first of all it's kind of
driven by data
so
a lot of these companies like netflix
and stuff they got a lot of data about
uh user because they would probably like
see what the user has been watching um
so they have lots of you know data about
users and also the items because like
you know they would have the whole kind
of
library of movies and shows that they
would know
uh some information about it right so
um
the recommender is
kind of
useful to make some personalized
recommendations
so uh of course you can you know let's
say you you start a streaming service
that's not netflix then you could
actually start by just oh let's see
what's popular right now right and just
recommend that to everybody um i think
yeah there's
some some services that do that i think
uh you know we don't know what like
sometimes we don't know whether it's
personalized or not sometimes just like
all popular stuff will just pop up
um but you know uh
we want to do a little bit better than
that not just like everybody watch the
same set of movies or the popular movie
would get more popular and the movie
that is not popular as a start that
would get sink down so
sometimes like more useful to make
personalized recommendations if i for
example i
know that if you like comedy i'll give
you all the recommendations about comedy
right so
um for
an online business it's very important
for that because uh for example
before this internet shopping thing and
internet um service that is so readily
available we would probably let's say go
to a shop right because i remember when
i was younger i you know
as a young lady i love going to cosmetic
shops so i would go to cosmetic shops
and go there and there would be a sales
person approaching me and because i
would be a professional customer right
so someone would come to me and say like
what are you looking for um i think this
really suited for your skin type and
things like that right so um so this is
like some human interaction there but
nowadays like let's say if you buy
things from amazon like you don't have a
sales person come and ask you like what
are you looking for today are you
looking for cosmetic are you looking for
electronics are you looking for you know
books and other stuff so um
so for an online business uh it how can
we know what do you want right uh also
you know if if it's back in the old days
you know like when there's salesperson
so if you talk to a uh experienced
salesperson they would kind of have
after talking to you for a while they
would have an idea of like what you like
then they would kind of recommend stuff
to
to you know personalize to to what you
would like but if we're doing an online
business then you know um
how do we know so we use the power of
the data right so we build recommenders
um
so there are a few types of different
recommenders out there uh there's also
like
something we call a content based system
that is uh basically we just look at
you know all these uh different kind of
um you know
stuff that we're selling and then kind
of group them into different groups like
like i mentioned before you know movies
you can have comedy romance horror
sci-fi others like you can group them by
their content but also there's something
called a collaborative filtering system
that is um based on how people react to
different things
we have an idea
that you know
what things should be recommended and
i'll go a little bit into details later
there's also a hybrid system that means
you know i won't stick with just one
method i would just mix and match so
just a combination of the two you know
everything else just
go into the hybrid category
um so content-based system like i said
before uh for example i am currently in
love with this cowboy box anime so is
anime
not new animes made in i think me in the
90s maybe i i'm not sure but like i
watch a lot of them so um probably what
i would get uh from recommendation you
know some something more um you know
intuitive would be like oh you like
cowboy people of the anime maybe you
would like the live action
series that is made by netflix right so
okay so um
but that's not always true at least from
my experience i don't like the live
action series so um so based on the
content sometimes it hits a miss for
example movies right we for example
really loved the first movie i loved the
first uh pirates of the caribbean movie
but if you recommend me the newest one
then maybe i won't like it because you
know
a lot of these movies you know we say
that oh the first one is good and then
this the sequel is not as good so maybe
i won't like it so
uh that's got some drawback there so if
you just based on the content it's
sometimes not very accurate
um so collaborative filtering system
that is something that would have more
kind of um
you know i would say a little bit more
sophisticated for example um it's it's
kind of based on what people
have an opinion about something for
example a movie that got you know if all
the
people uh that love
for example like let's say okay
both of us watch a lot of anime
so um you know if i watch a anime and i
think that's good you know like cowboy
people then like maybe it would get
recommended to you so
it's just kind of mimic the in the real
world that if you know if i like certain
things and then maybe i have friends who
like certain things what would i
recommend to my friend right so that's
more like a collaborative filtering
system there's more user ratings that is
involved
um but there's a problem because
some of the items may be more popular
right um
then
more you know if it's more popular then
there will be more opinion about it and
the chances are they would get
recommended more but um if there's a
something let's say someone make a very
niche movie or like some item that is
very
um niche that like it's not nothing else
like it in the market
then i won't get a lot of reviews then
i understand
sorry
it happens sometimes
i think it always happened in five days
to learn i don't know why um but anyway
so like if if like if something is uh
not so popular people haven't seen it so
much there isn't got a lot of reveal
then
you know it won't get recommended and
it's not fair it's not good
so that's why we sometimes we use the
hybrid system but um
but uh to make things simple in our
workshop we would just use the
collaborator filtering system um so what
we could how we would achieve that
because we would need some reviews right
so the reviews that we would get is uh
it's from movie lens data set um i think
i do have the link to it at the github
repo so if you already go to the github
repo
then you would find the link to download
these two csv from them make sure you
get the full version
you haven't get to the ripple yet i will
show you the link
again but don't worry so go to the
github repo you'll be able to
go to the movie lens
set and then get these two files from
the full version um so you download a
full version of the zip file and then
you unzip it you will have these two
csvs um after that you put that in the
same ripple that i
probably you already have cloned it so
you put that in the same repo then
it's not working
so uh
so like like i said this is a collect
collaborator filtering method
actually uh we'll have some problem
because uh some movies are more popular
they got more ratings some of them don't
also that on the other way to look at
things right so there are some uses that
they
review everything but there are some
users they just review
a few things maybe something that they
like the most or something they hate the
most i don't know um but you know
we don't want the maybe like user who
just review one or two movies so
so we have to do some filtering
for our data so we'll dive into it later
so yes so before i go into this detail i
will give people another chance to get
the rapport so as either go to my github
so my name check thing in one word so
github.com and i put that there and then
knn recommender or you can find it in my
repo list or you can use the the
shortcut there that's like bitch.le and
slash pi data london 22.
so um yeah
i hope you
maybe i should give you more time sorry
i'm just skipping but yeah
so yeah
yes
yes i think for maybe for this workshop
purposes you can get the short data sets
for now i think um
but
i haven't tried on the short data set so
if it doesn't work very well it's fine
you can try it again at home when you
get the internet yet but you can you can
make do with that for now just so we can
complete the exercises
so that's a good suggestion actually so
if you find that oh my god my internet's
so bad then download the small version
for now
the last one for taking an hour okay
that's really bad okay download the
small version sorry
okay yeah
download the small version for for today
but you can
of course try it at home when you have
time
um
so while you already kept i hope we are
already
in the process of downloading
so
let's
have a look at what we're going to do
today
while the thing is getting download
so
first of all we have to prepare the data
so um
again like the problem is that there
will be long tails so if you
plot everything as like you know plot a
user in one access
and then the rating in one the other
access you will see that there's there
will be actually like some user that
hasn't been that there's actually a lot
of user that hasn't been rating a lot of
movies
and if you do again like a movie and you
will see that actually there's a lot of
a lot of movies that hasn't been rated a
lot
so
especially if you're using the food data
set maybe it's less when you're using a
small data set but
if you if you observe that then
probably
the idea is that we have to do the
filtering
so
the way to do it is that we will create
some filters right so it's just pandas
you know we love pandas and then
appenders we can actually create filters
that for example we can set a threshold
that let's say if a movie received less
than 50 reviews then we just ignore it
or
a user that hasn't reviewed
let's say 50 movies that's quite a lot
or 10 i don't know movies again we
ignore that so we'll just
choose the the
you know the data point that actually is
like popular movie and active users so
uh we got a chance to do that
and then so actually the the way to do
it because like um
the project is already uh the skeleton
is already in the rep so um what we're
going to do is um
look for this uh pep data
method
inside that and then it's like pandas
then we create that filter
and then after that then we could uh
we could uh create the array
so
the the data that need to so we would
later put in our
k n nearest neighbor is that we need to
be a m by n array so we will have
so m is the number of movie and n is the
number of user so you can see that it's
actually like each
you know if you look at the m dimension
right so each one actually represent a
movie and then
um the user's rating will be actually
the uh so the vector itself right this
will be like the characteristic of that
movie
judging by all these n number of users
so uh from there actually you can think
that when we do the k n so movies that
got similar rating from similar users
they would be
similar um
judging by the k n so
and that's that's what we're gonna do
that's why we have to do the um
the privet
uh to to make the that m
times n array
it will be clearer when we look at the
code but just get the idea for now
um and then because this matrix actually
the m times n matrix is going to be a
huge matrix right
so this matrix is going to be
again because
it would be rare to find a user that
raised every single movie
so
a lot of there will be a lot of zeros in
this uh in this array um so we call that
a sparse matrix and
spam smart matrix if you if we represent
it in the normal numpy array or um you
know that would actually cause a lot of
memory because
we store all the zeros
so
if we use sci-fi sparse array splash
matrix actually it will
use a better mechanism to store it so we
just store you know where things got
rated and it will be more efficient so
we can we can actually transform it
because uh
that's actually uh it will work in our
model as well
so
talk about our model uh our model will
be like i said a collaborative filtering
model
it's is it user based or item based so
like i said the m and n array before so
each
vector so we have m vectors so each
vector is n long right n is the number
of users so
so each vector is actually representing
one movie so it's item-based so there
are items there are movies
um and then similar movies gonna be
clustered together so if uh those end
users if they rage
a movie and b movie you know similarly
then you would get us you know similar
factors and they would be similar so if
you do that with the k n nearest
neighbor model then actually
you know the model tell you oh these two
vectors are very close and i think they
are similar
so we got to do that um
also from the k n model
again it will be clearer when i show you
the code so in the k n model you can
also say like how am i going to
calculate the proximity of the two
vector and then
we can use different method uh one
method that we use is the cosine
similarity method which we'll go through
in the code
so
um yeah this is like
we would
uh where can we get the model is in
succulent so uh
in the skeleton of the code uh it's
already there which is nearest neighbor
but the parameter can be set so it will
be set in another
um
another function there it's like set
model parameters
and so inference is the one that we also
have to work on a little bit because i
leave some code out
then we have to
actually use the model to find the n
nearest neighbor
from the you know get their distance how
far apart they are
and also get the
you know the
we need to find those n
similar ones right so we need to get the
index so we can later map it back
to
the title of the movie
so um yeah and then we try different
settings as well so again it will be
much clearer if i show you the code but
let's just
let that go first is there any questions
for now
no very puzzled very very personal but
how about downloading is it is it a good
the small data set oh good you already
got it
yes okay good okay so
um
yeah so uh
and then after we build it we'll run the
wonder code in the command line first um
there's already some instructions in the
github repo tell you how to run it
um we just need to run it once then we
can try the the browser version because
we need that pico file that we already
will process the data and then we'll get
paid code and then if we once we have
the pickle file we can um
if you run it again it will be much
faster also you
so
also it can be run on the browser so
yeah
so uh
yeah so that's that's that's how we're
gonna do it so let's uh
so oh also this is like if you wanna try
the price script and the browser version
you can follow these instructions it's
already it's also the instructions on
the github repo um
so pi script
is the thing that lets you run python
browser if you're interested there will
be a talk about it on sunday i think so
yeah
and then so this is i would i'll leave
this for later so let's go let's go to
do the code or at least have a look at
the code let me go through this
oh actually i already have ah that's
fine let me zoom in a little bit if i
can zoom in control plus right yes
right so
so uh you you've already got the project
file there like i said the download the
csvs and i put that in the same repo
github doesn't allow me to put the big
data there so i can't do that so okay
oops okay so i hope it's clear enough no
it's not well if it's not clear then
look at
you look at the one in your computer but
i would i would try to like go over the
code a little bit so i can explain what
i just talked about like five minutes
ago
so
so this is the skeleton of the file um
credit i didn't create that from scratch
by myself it's another um
you know data scientists for a child
talented data scientist you know created
the code and write the blog post about
it but um i do some modification with it
of course but um yeah
let's be on based on that so
uh this is the k n recommender
so
maybe first of all we have a look that
we are using a few of the libraries that
we know and love like pandas we're going
to prepare the data using pandas and we
also use the sparse matrix that's called
c
s r matrix so we're going to use that
later so remember that so that's the uh
the sparse matrix that we're using um
our model is the nearest neighbor so we
call that from cyclone so it's already
there
also there was some uh fuzzy wuzzy thing
which is like uh
that's mainly used for when you enter a
movie name it's just try to find like oh
the the closest one right so
because if you have a misspelling i
think
once like fussy matching matches it will
still work so that's fine
so you don't have to type in exact movie
name um sometimes you know we we forgot
an s or something so it's fine
right
so
um this is the k n recommender so you
can see that the the line there this is
the important line here
whoops okay
so uh the model is the nearest neighbor
so if we want to use the model
what we got to do is to call self.model
so instead of creating a new model every
time
we create one model in this recommender
so every time we just call self.model
and of course
when we set it up there's also some
other like settings we could have we
could have the path to the movie and
ratings
the default is just the same um the same
place
in this together with this code so
that's why i said oh put the csv
together here so then you don't have to
fiddle around with this setting
also there's threshold here it just says
zero but
we can change that
so
um so there's this is the one that we
changed the parameter we can change the
threshold like i said so uh you know
it's f-zero we'd be like oh uh you know
i need
10 ratings right so you have 10 there
things like that so
yeah so a minimum number of rating
received by user for each movie or
minimum number of ratings a user given
so if a user hasn't give like let's say
10 ratings then they are out if a movie
haven't received 10 you can set the
other one as 10 as well so if a movie
hasn't received 10 ratings by
all the users then they're out so this
is the filtering just to make um
just to make the
things much better
i think we could you can set that to
zero to as a start because i think if
it's a small data set i think it is okay
to use all of them
uh this one the code is based on if we
use the full data set so i think as an
experiment you can just you know set the
threshold to zero for now um but again
like it won't be a very good recommender
because
we are using a just a sample data set
for now just for internet
download reasons
but
yeah let's just pretend that the
recommender works
unfortunately so
but yeah i can show you like where it's
actually got set uh here all the way
down so
so it won't be set by user it will be
set by us who are the engineer so we are
taking a role of engineering so you can
change this into
zero for now because we're using a small
data set so if you change these two so
go all the way to the to the bottom and
change this to zero then uh we'll use
everything
so so so try that as a start first um
yeah
since we are using a small data set for
now
so
um okay
so uh the model parameters we can also
change the model parameters like i said
the k n
nearest neighbor there is actually
you can
tell
what metric it used to calculate the
similarity between two vectors
so there are different ways here that
you could choose the metrics here
you can choose you know
l1 l2 ukrainian or cosine or so i think
the default here is cosine but feel free
to change to the others
when you rerun the model to see if
there's any other different changes
also there's different algorithm you
could use as well um i think algorithm
is is something that i don't totally
understand so i would just skip that
part but um
yeah i think it's just like how we got
calculated some of them may be more
optimal for some data things like that
but yeah um you can also choose how much
uh how how many
uh neighbors that we're gonna be using
but this usually this will just like be
a option that we get from the command
line you know
options
so
the number will be how many neighbors we
get and how many recommendations we
would give
so
yeah
um okay
so this is a path data is like where we
work on so you see that was this like
to-do thing right here it's like i i
leave all the code for you um the
original one that you know is finished
you can see it from the finished branch
but um i recommend you to spend some
time to fill it in um
because we'll have time in this workshop
so you can try working it yourself or
working it with your friend next to you
to see like how you can create a filter
so we're using panda so
really it's just an exercise of
filtering using pandas
and then afterward we have to do the
privilege table to make that matrix m
times n matrix that i talked about
and then also we need a mapping because
um the
the k n n only give you the index of the
movie so
we need to find back the title which
that's why we need this mapping
this hash map that we need
um another thing is that we would
take that
array the m times n array and make it
into a
splash matrix so we we just use the
sidekick the one we got from
scipy to get this
yep so this is the the bit that we have
to complete uh
today in this workshop then you will
have something that
that the data will be prepared right so
we still have a little bit of things to
work on until it will completely work
so um for the first c matching again
it's not the focus of today's workshop
so
just just leave it
be
and then in inference is the one that we
actually call the model and then we do
the find the k nearest neighbor
from it
so um
so we'll fit the data so the data is the
one that we prepare in the other method
so it would be the sparse matrix
and then this is just like if you put in
the movie title you just try to find
index by using the mapping and the first
matching thing
and then
here to do this is the important thing
this is like where we actually get the k
nearest neighbor from the model
um
so you get the distance and the indexes
uh we will have to use that later so
get that and then um
then you can get a list
of of the uh of the index of the
recommendation and then um
we have to use the uh the mapping as
well to get all the title back
then um then we just put it back to the
system and then we can
make a recommendation
make a commendation so although this one
is just running the whole thing yeah
so yeah so if you complete the inference
and the prep data actually this one will
be working
of course if you scroll all the way to
the to the bottom here you can change
the setting like i said change this to
zero as a start because we're using a
small data set
and then the model parameters i think
you can try the default one and then but
later you can change
all these settings um i think mainly you
can change the cosine into some like
other
other
metrics to calculate the similarity so
you can see whether that makes a
difference
and then
we can run it
so
i think i'll give you time to start
working on this if you have questions
you can ask me
um and then
because this is not my computer i don't
think i have python here so i can't
really run it but um yeah i would just
maybe like give you time to work on it
and then ask questions if you have any
so um
know more about recommenders
so yeah for this model uh like i said
introductory uh i don't think it would
be something that you want to deploy for
a commercial use
because it suffer uh some drawbacks like
uh popularity bias you know um it would
bias towards the more popular item you
also also have the co-star problem you
know if you for example i have a new
movie i haven't received any ratings it
won't work so um yeah but it's i hope
you had fun today um that's the that's
more important most important thing i
hope also i kind of give you a starting
point if you want to learn more
so
like i said i didn't started this from
scratch there's a blog post that
inspired me to do it the the author also
have the the code there so uh if you
want to know more visit the blog post
here that i have the link here also the
link will be in the repo as well
um check that out so for those of you
who have tried to run it in the browser
again is use a pi script that lets you
run python on the browser there will be
a talk about it on sunday so if you are
interested if you like the look of it
go to the talk you know more or talk to
me afterwards
so yeah you can
you know find the project wrapper there
so there's two branches in the repo um
if i can show you here quickly or not
yeah so actually there's two branches so
the one that we work on is the ming
branch here
if you kind of are struggling when you
try to complete it at home you can go to
the finished branch that would be
the completed one so you can just run
this
if you want to see what the finished
product looks like
or if you need a little bit of help you
can have a quick peek of this and then
ah actually that's why i'm struggling
with and then come back to your code and
fix it
so um yeah i think that's more or less
it if there's no more questions so you
can go and enjoy the coffee
again thank you so much for coming i
will be here
the whole weekend so talk to me if you
want to thank you